[Music]
hi everyone this is women's Grand Master
Sabina for sure and I'm here at the San
Luis chess club and you are watching
puzzlers paradise so for today I
prepared a couple more studies and then
we're going to see some fun tile tactics
well tactics from tiles games because
that's what I've been asked for by most
of the people at the club for in a long
time and I haven't done it so I thought
okay maybe today today is the day the
last day of teaching here for me at the
club so I thought why not make it a
little bit fun okay so let's get started
with this position what do we think
about this position who is better I'm
sorry
it's from whites perspective so black is
threatening to promote so what do you
think should be the result of this
position
do you think we can win or should we try
to be happy with the draw if we can find
it
you think drop good okay so any ideas on
how we can try to make a draw here with
white
well of course it's not so easy that
dries not very easy otherwise I wouldn't
give you this position so the natural
move that you're thinking about this
probably rook F want to try to stop the
pawn but exactly they'll take your
knight in there with those two points
they will be able to win and this is not
like a previous study that maybe I
showed before in one of the classes
where you know the Kings were blacks
King was restricted on the h-file and
white would just follow it just I don't
know if you've ever seen that study
white we just follow the king and if you
would get to the second rank then I
could you know I was able to what was I
able to do I was able to capture somehow
your pawn or no no no no if you were on
the second rank with the King so just
imagine a pawn a black pawn in a three a
black pawn in b2 and a white row can be
one I'll make it green so they keep that
and then imagine that they are just
these pieces are not there and then
White's King is over here and blacks
King is over here and so basically what
was happening if black would try to come
King to h2 white was able to approach
with his King to attack these pawns
because any push a two with a loud way
to capture with check and then capturing
a two but here it's a completely
different story right
I mean and the reason black was trying
to to move their King and not push is of
course white was threatening checkmate
but this is a completely different story
so let's just get rid of these colors
because they are not really helpful
right now for the current position so
look f1 doesn't seem to be the right way
to go for right so what other ideas
should we come up with
so is there any other way we can stop
the promotion well good point yes so
fork is a nice tactical motif that you
want to consider see if you can make it
happen when black promotes we can try to
have some fork ideas but obviously you
cannot make it immediately because the
pattern for the Queen promoting mb1 and
the king in d4 is not really something
that exists not with a knight at least
so we need to consider some potential
arrangement between our knight in our
rook so that when we you know we try to
give a check and push blacks King
somewhere it might lead to a yeah a fork
I'll give you a hint for the first move
Knight here completely counterintuitive
but let's see what's the idea when I
promote
where do we give the check now
Knight d5 is not to check ah light b5
good so now can I come here
93 can I come here 93 so I have King III
and King D 3 left so let's go King D 3
it's probably the same what next where
do we give the check now rook d5 or Rock
f3
so we know that these two squares are
mined technically because you have 93
and we know that these two squares are
kind of mine too because you have 93
right so if you give this check I have
to go over here and then what Knight to
c3 and if I give you this little check
over here I will take your knight the
next move
so rookie five obviously doesn't work
either so we're out of checks and out of
options and this Queen like you often
see studies where the opponent promotes
but the queen is somewhat trapped so
doesn't have any good ways to get it
active but this is not the case so in
this position you actually give this
cheque as you said those squares are
mined so black is forced to go King to
d2 what to do now yes rook F to yes only
check right if black goes back we will
have the repetition right draw we're
happy okay obviously okay not obviously
obviously we cannot go here so we can
eliminate that we also cannot go here we
can eliminate that too why look at fine
can we go we can go here or here
a rookie to king d3 you're trying to be
tricky but you might have just messed up
now you don't need to be tricky in this
position because once again right these
squares will not be you able to be
utilized by blacks King so you can just
give a check and then again he has to go
back to the two and we've got the same
position as before right okay so if they
go up there we just repeat the position
and we'll have a draw so King you want
actually let me go back to the two mine
so checking your one good now rookie two
very good and has to play King f1 and
this is how you make it draw just repeat
over here you can utilize all of those
squares to sacrifice well only two is
sacrificing technically I look and
that's how you draw with white but you
see how important this night and rook
coordinated they can create all these
you know Czech motifs and simply you
know draw the game but you have to do it
just the right way and don't get tempted
to make sacrifices of the rook if you
don't see a follow up if they don't take
right your opponent is not always forced
to care well in this case it wasn't
forced so very good so I have one more
study which is quite nice I love the
study
it is why to move what do you think
about this position yes
oK you've got half of it done yes so
let's discuss it first so you're
obviously quite stuck with your pieces
over there and your king is not in the
box of the beep for pawn so if you just
were to take the pawn in b5 you're
completely giving up all of your chances
to a draw because that point will just
go to promote and there's no cell mate
so you need to find the stalemate
pattern so king c5 version very well
this this yes yes so now you found that
draw pattern and of course if I promote
to a queen all all good right I'll go
for a white but we're going to promote
to a root what do you do now okay so
let's find some winning idea for black
yes
because it still made
you have no moves with white that's why
you have to promote to give to allow
white to go to a2 and if you promote any
other piece I will go back take your
pawn in b5 and then you have no chance
to win with with black so black is still
trying to win here so he's going to
promote to a rook you said King e2 and
now let's try to figure out how black
and try to play for a win here
obviously if you just play rube before
king a3 there's no progress how does
black play for a win think for the
opponent to that's the hardest thing to
do
King before okay that's a nice idea for
black to play for a wing and did so rook
each one once again you know here it
makes no sense to do this you're just
that yes you just stay with the King on
third drink anytime you look moves they
they bring their king up and and your
king is a block 82 it's still made non
stalemate technically right so in this
position look h1 okay so you said very
well King b3 or King a3 the same thing
rook h6 now it is very important to make
this move if you play the king before
what do you do now
yes if you play King a5 we'll play
before and you don't have to draw
anymore so if you play King h3 for
example how does black win
exactly they can always give you the
move and at some point you need to exit
with your king from in front of the pawn
and then they just wait with the rook
and then you have to keep moving your
king and then the pawn will go to
promotion just make sense for everyone
so like where do you go now with white
you don't have you can go wherever you
want where do you want to go I went to
a3 but you can go to b3 too but where do
you want to go because we push the pawn
and now like you're not to stalemate
right and you cannot catch this pawn is
just going right but then I promote and
you have this extra material but it's
useless because you cannot force me to
exit with the King from in front of the
pawn to promote if you cannot do that
it's just I will just get a queen and
then win right so here this move is very
important King a3 it's the I would say
it's double exam the idea is as follows
when you take I
now I clicking before and now you are
kind of if you move yeah if you move
your look I take the pawn and it's a
draw if you don't move the rook you'll
see in a second what happens you can
also try to trick me by playing rook c6
or look somewhere in the 6th rank but do
we play King before no we play King b3
and now when you take now we're play
King before we just need to make sure
that when you take that pawn and b6 we
can play King before to block it upon so
and now you try to bring your King right
King a7 or King c7 I had it like either
one is fine and now what do we do it
white to make a draw
yes yes
okay so now we can take with the rook or
with the king which one strike him first
it's pretty much the same Oh bishop
where
and what's your plan hmm
drip it just stay with your Bishop over
here
keep the pawn attacked and we know
already that the rook versus Bishop is a
draw right
so black finds himself in a situation
where they have to stay with their king
and rook to protect the pawn and b5 if
they don't you just grab it and you grab
it with check and then you can move the
bishop and it's going to be a draw so
there were a couple of steps in this
study first if we go from the start
first we had to find that still mating
idea which wasn't too difficult right
but we had to find it then we had to
find blacks idea to try to win and he
had to go grab the pawn and that's the
only way like regardless of how you you
go you can go through c1 to d1 wherever
you wanted you're still getting the same
at the same position and then you had to
find this great idea of stalemate or
actually not stalemate sorry
zooks Bank position for black because
here the his rook is trapped and he can
never try to improve the position and
the promotion there was very important
now you can tell me that here after King
g7 Queen if black takes you with the
rook what do we play
very good and we still get the same kind
of idea or not what do you do now
you take the pawn you take the pawn
regardless because after check yes and
this is a drop nice hopefully let's have
some fun with some tile games so
everyone all the levels here are going
to enjoy hopefully these tactical
positions way to move
can turn the last move very good
okay everyone has seen it and I mean I
can go fast but I want everyone to see
so we go with this check you have to
come to go to h7 and now my favorite
right my favorite and then meat of
course you can do that but then you just
sacrifice your queen right you want to
sacrifice your queen to to escape the
mate but we're going to try to just make
sure we know what's happening if you
don't sacrifice material why to move
some of these are very simple I just
kind of was told that everyone wants to
see some tau positions and it's you know
this is the session about you know fun
positions not full games so just showing
the ends yeah yes
okay yeah
okay
and then after Queen f7 you don't take
the Queen right yeah I'm sorry
no it's pinned that's why we don't we
don't we don't take the Queen we we take
care first to to have that me and that
nice mate threatened okay so in this
position both players are attacking and
black has a very annoying threat check
and mate right so if you don't do things
with check we're struggling here so
obviously we start with the check right
and then what do we do when we sacrifice
our Queen we should always have some way
to back it up with the rest of our
pieces and black might want to escape in
g7 so
mmm-hmm has to go somewhere in there
okay hey it's right simple now and then
we take the cream yes okay
what are they too simple and that's why
you are you are so confused
which one is it hmm you using everything
be confident in your knowledge why not
why wouldn't you see everything White
has a big threat
told you they are simple
yes okay maybe too simple I don't know
now I feel bad I feel bad you wanted
Towe so I mean
yes and mate okay let's see a more a
little bit longer of a position
yes so this is really really early in in
the opening and this is a very typical
idea right taking there so especially
when you take there with check I
actually play the game not long ago and
and I had this kind of idea I just could
never make it work because even if I
would sacrifice my bishop even if my
opponent wouldn't take that would be
Knight f3
but obviously here there are some
options that the white can play so let's
let's check what's happening after
castle yes look you don't you don't have
sufficient pieces to try to mate so
you're happy with the with the exchange
right so in the game after Bishop h3
white played the smooth what do we do
it takes d4 Bishop takes h3
do you take c3 quintics
III
ruijven now you take here and the
problem is that now we're like if you
take the bishop will have an extra piece
so white ended up taking but now after
c5 Knight had to go Bishop somewhere the
position is just amazing for black not
only do you have material advantage but
wise king remember it remained in the
center yeah
every single yeah everything is is
awesome four black-and-whites can't
decide good
okay what do we think about this
position
hmm
Luke takes e5 Queen takes f3 check
white is dominating this position all
their pieces are much better placed
even if white doesn't have a tactical
idea here they should be better much
better
if yes but that's a little bit slowly
right like if you don't make moves with
tempo your opponent will be able to do
something else and when you actually
have the threat they will be able to
defend it so if you just play queen g4
you have known I mean you you attack my
rook okay I will take your rook in d5
make the trade then I went upon Queen
takes f7 rook takes f7 you can't your
pin
so we have this amazing thing here that
we want to utilize right how do we do it
very good night except seven because
there cannot capture right why it's in
silver right so black took here
of course only move who's just waiting
to see like here's some someone and
Queen d7
g5 you mean
'if I've it's a free free night right
Knight to g5 black push c4 and how do we
convert this position with an extra pawn
what's our plan
d6 guys d6
this 19 g5 is very strong you not only
have you know mates in h7 when you have
a 19 g5 you also have mates in f7 and
you have diagonal openings and you have
this mothered mate as well right and you
have back rank Mei - I mean here not
really cuz the bishop can go to have
faith but you have all of these ideas
that you have to always you know be on
the look for so now black plate c3 but
after take what what was happening
bishop a faint
tha
the bishop a failure tonight here
and now you're it's not simple for you
to keep your phone maybe you go here
but can i play queen no damn liquid a
six
you have this check annoying check true
and now maybe you can play Knight well
this would last for quite some time this
disposition you have to play for quite
some time we had just think the time
because then I mean you're threatening
this which is not only check check
wiener so threatening
well the the mate the smothered mate
supposedly and also you have threatened
the a6 pawn so if black tries to put the
Queen to bring the Queen back you can
take an a6 as well so you'll have two
extra pawns makes it much easier and you
don't allow your opponent any counter
play right so this 6 and after c3 check
here
it's not really smothered I mean at
night of 796 Queen g8 but if you go back
I cannot do the smothered mate right so
I can just take the pawn right two
points why do you move Cal to move
what's happening in this position
okay that's an idea and can black defend
after Bishop c4
look at this king so with white you have
supposedly just the Queen close to to
attack but a lot of the pieces are
really close by they can get into attack
quite easily this rook on the
third-ranked could prove itself helpful
certainly you have this idea you have
the knight ready to come into play and
this bishop can come into play as well
just need to find the right way
otherwise black might be able to try to
trade your queen and then things will
not go as planned so you want to start
with Bishop c4 right oh sorry you want
to start but if you do rube takes up
three you will never have Bishop c4
again so bring the bishop first no that
was good this is good I just I want you
to see it all the way I don't want to
tell yes this is good let's do it I want
to see how how far ahead you're
calculating so if we play we we need to
bring a lot of our pieces into play but
the order in which you bring them is
very important so for example if you
bring the Bishop to c4 right we said
that black has two moves this or this
which of them is not so great
okay let's look at these six first or
let's which one do you want to look at
first we can look at this first bishop
okay it's a condition what do we do now
ninety-five can I take
I take the bishop
ah
right yeah
yep this is it
correct yeah that's the way there's a
solution night 9:00 to 5:00 there what
if I play yes II 6 that's my question
first-first you should think about
bishop takes c6 if it works
why not quint xe6 okay Quinn g6 check
King h8 Luke c7 that's the line that you
should think about first right you sex
mm-hmm
Black has a final move check
he resigned here but if if there's no
night to fun what do you mean what did
you say
King H - you said all right no okay
because King gage - losers and that's it
and the mate cannot be stopped and one
of these squares is going to be made if
you play the g8 I can meet you in h6 -
well
huh what do you mean no I just I made
arrows for you
I made arrows I didn't touch tonight I'm
sorry okay so I mean I'm trying to make
you calculate a little bit like by
putting the arrows just to make sure you
know where they are
that is true I mean it's it's it's tough
when you're calculating different lines
but you would try to often make the most
Force one first or you try to calculate
the most first one first and the one
with night of five four nine teach five
there wasn't really quite force there
were a lot of moves that white that
black would play maybe but this one this
a six is just a pawn push that
automatically opens up the seventh rank
and you're telling yourself there's no
way I can let that go so you just take
it bring your rook and then the majors
come I mean just know it's Tao you
wouldn't let anyone escape so easily
right sure which which moment in which
like this okay
yeah queen g6 first the idea of this
move which I didn't explain earlier was
that you are taking the king away from
the control of of f7 so when you bring
your rook rook f7 is not possible
because you take it yeah yeah if you if
you play rook there first
rook f7 and then maybe you're still
winning but you have to keep trying
actually probably are still winning
because you have this yeah but maybe
there's something else that black can do
if you play rook rook c7 immediately
maybe not I don't see anything else
though maybe they can sacrifice the
Queen no could you six I take it but you
can take you kinda have to take and then
you give this check and you should still
be winning but it don't take you some
time
no they don't have more pieces you still
have like Queen and night for two ropes
so you're definitely yeah yeah but the
other one is mate
probably or way more material okay let's
see at Albert Vinick
I think so yeah yep
you take all the night's wife what
6:9 take 769 takes f6 okay and then 1937
you still have the night I have a lot of
nights let's evaluate this position okay
you are hearing you know you know why
sometimes I I did like teaching tactics
positions this is not tactics like
puzzlers paradise it's like a fun fun
way of putting it right we had some
studies yes because people don't try to
understand the position they know there
needs to be a sacrifice in the position
so they are only looking for that so the
bad thing about this mindset is that
because you're not thinking about the
position you're not trying to understand
what's happening on the board you forget
about this position like maybe you saw
it before in another class but because
you probably did the same thing you just
try to sacrifice something to make it
work
it didn't past your brain you just or
the way it entered the same way its
exited so now you are you are finding
yourself with a new position that you
maybe have seen maybe not but you don't
know so the reason I like to evaluate
and you start understanding is because
these patterns that you keep seeing if
if you really reasoned with them when
they will come into your games in some
other fashion you will be able to use
them I know it takes way more time to
evaluate the position really I mean why
would we even do that but trust me it's
really really helpful even if now I bet
whatever the next person will say will
be a move now will not be an evaluation
but at least I I know I told you so I
have my conscience clear
now let's evaluate okay let's evaluate
the position before you say move please
at least tell me who is better here tell
me something about the position that's
good for white and something that's good
for black okay
so white has two marginal Knights this
Knight is also attacked but they have
two great rooks they have a nice bishop
the King is more safe compared to this
one which although it's an endgame still
being in the center with so many pieces
can be dangerous okay if this bishop
goes away yes these pawns will be weak
okay good at least reason with something
okay so now you have a move I assume yes
yes okay exactly
so you sacrifices double rook sacrifice
double exchange sacrifice I guess but
you have this follow-up here King d6 and
now you take the rook okay but but it's
still not so simple right still not so
simple so let's see how the game
continues rook c5
I'm still trying some things okay it's
because you have the pattern but you
know when you play a game you also have
to evaluate the position that you get
afterwards especially if it's two pieces
for a rook that those positions are
never a hundred percent clear in my
opinion so what do we do
95 who takes you five be careful
see for Bishop d3 check
he play Knight h6 to keep the pressure
over there he he has no choice though in
this position you have no way to to save
your pawn bishop takes you to seems to
be right but I bet most of you didn't
think that following a following move
follow-up move for black after you take
the route no no he wants to take with
the bishop in c2 because
you don't need to
so what do you want to do after Bishop
takes you to you want to take the pawn
and after this move this you will
encounter if you're studying and game a
nothing game studies and game studies
you will see this pattern a lot when
somehow you have a pawn and the king and
your opponent has a knight and Bishop or
somehow they stay with Knight and Bishop
and you have a move like this it saves
you otherwise of course you're going to
lose so 96 you want to take in f7 and
think about it I mean you want to try
like for example if black were to take
here
I believe tal was thinking to take and
then take this point - and suddenly your
Knights will be linked I'm not sure if
with this one or the other one but
anyways your Knights would be linked and
then it would be maybe easier for you to
- to go yes
so after night of 96 between play f6
what do we do
they want to take our pond without
anything giving anything in return
so you want to continue putting pressure
in f6 so 98 or 94 is a way to put
pressure right he went here because here
it's a little bit more it has more moves
and also if you decide to defend your
pawn I can decide to defend my pawn as
well I always try to have multiple ideas
when you play so now Bishop takes if yes
ya think we go back and then what do you
do
I think I can give you this check
I'm not exactly sure where you go but I
will wait for you now to play b5 to
chase me away and then I want to play 93
maybe so I'm not sure where you move
yeah I guess it is 93 okay five
but I'm hanging five
yeah so I need to decide how exactly I
want to give it you also had the
opportunity to go here to try to stay to
try to go over there but probably this
would be this would might lead to a draw
if we repeat that we can repeat the
position here I'm having trouble getting
this night into play if you just stay
with your okay all right so anyways that
probably was a better move for for black
but Bishop takes you to Knight takes f6
we are much happier if they take here
and we take back because then black will
not have a passport yet right
Oh actually if you take immediate today
I give you intermediate check yeah sorry
take
this was quite interesting and now I
didn't want to do I wanted to play this
this this this this and I don't know I I
don't know what's happening here
it's very tricky I wouldn't want to play
this or have to calculate it yeah but I
also take here but your night is right
in front of your pawn stopping them so
this is going to be very tricky and
needs to be analyzed I cannot give you
an evaluation on the spot to tell you
what would happen yes normally the
bishop is better because they are pawns
on both sides of the board yes yes
that's why blacks should be better but I
don't think I mean I don't think it's
clear so in this position after take
don't talk back and now you get he took
obviously you cannot take back because
I'm a little shack rook takes B 3 F 4
and now okay with two knights I think
it's much easier you know check he
brought six King I'll just show you the
end of the game but okay these two
checks to tell you the truth they help
you with a rock a little bit but they
help me more to bring my King more
active yeah yeah but it's hard to
improve the position with black because
if you push the five for example I think
we have Knight G to e4 check
I cling like gta4 and then start pushing
the Jeep on or maybe this one you think
and then going but if I put this one
then King e5 No
well I wasn't going to stop yours going
to do this
nice - yeah
oopsie sorry here
so what's happening like
well I think I think I think this should
be a dropper let's see exactly right if
you can't get your night here should be
behind the pond you need to defend it
behind the pond otherwise right so now I
can just let's see I push
here
wait wait then you have this but I don't
know if it helps you oh look at this
beauty look at this beauty this this
check so yeah so I'm just like analyzing
you stuff here so here I guess we have
to be very careful of how we're playing
with black so probably we should push
here first you have to go we agree yeah
now I don't know if I should push again
but probably might not yeah now your
King is too far from the pawn yes so the
thing is if you wouldn't right you can
huh hah
what do you mean save it oh and you make
it you make it right on time hmm so I
guess it's raining your your line is
winning too but we went way ahead like
we this was just a line right we're just
talking about it's quite nice it's quite
a nice line I mean can you imagine
having to calculate all of this and just
works by one temple everything works to
one temple I mean this is just this is
just tough to play so anyways so in the
game both viniq ended up giving this
check and then King f3 but you know this
should help white after all and now of
course we push the pawn check f5
f6 f7 and now
very good and but now what would have
happened if black had taken here
come on simple simple chess yes of
course
not if six-night there what did you
think you're going to lose I'm showing
your lives to lose no of course not
this is very tricky check and then there
stop the rook and then promote yeah
we're not going to lose this come on so
b3 b3 come on yeah same this what's the
same thing working here no because after
this there's King g6 right and then
you're losing so 92 right
hmm
where what do you want to do
you cannot promote it on time right I
have like a million checks to give you
an L start grabbing all the material if
your pawn is not even a second-rank you
pretty much have no cheek no chance so
the game ended as follows B 392 b2 came
back we have another point to write King
before trying to get rid of this night
and then of course protect promote the
pawn but this is quite nice I mean I
liked how he went all the way there and
now he's coming back
no you don't like it okay okay
c5 Queen thank you very much
and now c4
check came here
how do I win this guys it's not so
difficult
you have a lot of ways to win why is not
easy you can play for example
King do you want for example why is this
not winning he didn't play that he play
nebula but why is this not winning what
do we do now
no moves right it just seems scary but
it's not really so in the game he just
wait how is it he plain ib1 in medicine
and mblaq resigned but it's the same
thing you don't need to be scared you
have wait way more material than black
dust so now the niger stars so the only
way the black would have played better
was there when they had the repetition
with luke a5 rook c5 potentially would
have given them some chances but maybe
white would have just given up the pawn
the same way as they did in the game and
then just go for the for the pawns on
the Kings side how was today's lesson
was it okay yeah I mean I try to have
some simple ones
I wasn't sure who would show up and then
this is going to be longer but hopefully
there are some interesting ideas and
hopefully from now on when you want to
do tactics if you really want to improve
your play you will try to understand the
position first before you go for the
sacrifice
no no so like look if depends how you do
the tactics okay if you are on some
website I will not name anything cuz you
know it's videotape but if you are going
on some website where your rating
matters for you obviously I understand
why you wouldn't spend enough time to to
evaluate the position and try to
understand because you are really the
time matters but if you are putting it
you can't be on the same website just a
book yeah get a book set the time for
yourself half an hour maybe and then you
know get to get to solve the positions
during that time but also like the time
is just there so that you stay focused
during that amount of time you don't use
the time as a means to how to say like
as a means to worry yourself you use the
time as a means to just make sure to
stay focused during that amount of time
right yeah it's very important and then
try to understand because you really
want to use these positions these themes
to your benefit
[Music]